[Music]
wait did you guys watch tinder swindler
i know about it
i like brief i don't know about it what
do you know it's a guy uh basically
catfished a bunch of women no no he
didn't catfish how much he got money
from him or something he
didn't like the opposite of catfishing
to be honest until today i thought when
they were saying tinder swindler it was
a new name for west elm caleb oh no it's
this guy
um
this israeli guy
sam levi yes simon simon levi that's his
fake name he but it's not really him
he's basically a scammer
since the age of like 18 he has multiple
identities um he's like wanted by the
israeli government for fraud the
student's career fraudster and
he basically would establish
relationships over tinder
and then
in america uh no no you're over there
okay
and what he would do is he would like
match a girl and then
he would invite them out for coffee and
he'd he had a system where he would pass
them through like an experience of
opulence like high [ __ ] class right
away so one of the main focus uh people
like or one of the women who's like the
main focus of the doc
first thing he does he meets with her
for coffee and then he's like do you
want to go to um
[ __ ] turkey or some [ __ ]
and then he takes her on a private plane
there he's like i'm going to budapest
right now but i'm having such a good
time like do you just want to like come
on the plane with me and like we can
keep this date going okay so far he's
done nothing i do that on every date
yeah
yeah so then um so then after he kind of
like establishes that then he'll lead
them on and whatever and he has this
[ __ ]
scam where abruptly he will send them th
this the same image of his bodyguard
being attacked and then he sends them a
video of them like in an ambulance and
he's like
and he he kind of he prefixes this with
telling these girls like hey
if we're going to be together or like
kind of get more serious you have to
know like i work in the diamond industry
and when you when you look up his name
on google it shows that he's like the
son of a billionaire it was like
labeled like the like the iceman he's
like the king of diamonds whatever but
that was all fake that was all fake all
fake and so
he
then he'll like show them things like
look i got this in the mail like an
image of like a bullet like in the mail
and then like uh funeral flowers and
stuff like oh i have many enemies in
this business so
he will he will like roughly wake these
girls up the middle and i'd be like i've
just been attacked and he'll like send
them this you know whatever
he and then he'll say my security team
is advising like i have to shut down my
cards like their my location's being
tracked and then that's when he starts
to scam them for money like hey i'm
stuck here can you just send me like 10
or 20 grand i'll pay you next week and
so these girls go out and get loans yeah
like payday loans and they and they and
they open credit cards in their own name
yeah because they're like we can't
he's not like he's in danger i have to
open in my name because i love this guy
and i want to like make sure he's good
and he he'll go like i'll pay you back
like i just we just have to like get
through this patch where i'm being
tracked or whatever
and i'll pay you back i'm good for it
and so these girls end up being like
you know quarter of a million dollars in
debt
and then that's how he's funding the
next girl
yeah right so it's a ponzi scheme he
just keeps doing this over and over and
over again just leaving these girls in
the dust
and he just will pay for vacations on
these girls dimes with new girls and
then do the same thing with those girls
holy [ __ ] it's crazy i like this barely
was even a blip on my feet and
everything but everyone was so pissed at
west elm caleb and this is so much worse
oh yeah yeah this is infinitely worse
and so what you find out i mean will
either of you watch the doc yeah maybe
maybe all right well oh it's a
documentary yeah it's like a two-hour
thing on netflix basically he's he's
been he's gone to jail for this before
and his old scam was that he would tell
people he was like an enrage an israeli
intelligence agents
uh and then he would get money from them
i don't know is it a new scam with each
woman no so he went to jail and then he
figured out this new one with tinder but
what's crazy is so like i watched this
and then i watched the puppet master and
that's about another guy who basically
did the same thing but his scam was it
was in europe and this was like in the
90s he would tell people that he was
like an mi5 agent and he would
he started by targeting kids at a
college when there was like civil unrest
with um like irish uh the ira yeah yeah
um and he would be like oh like you're
not safe here like you have to come with
me and this and that and he had these
people fake on the run for [ __ ] 10
years jesus christ he was siphoning
money out of them and jeez man yeah
the puppet masters that was yeah that
was the puppet the craziest part of the
tinder swindler i'm gonna like ruin the
end for you but is that okay sure sure
is that
he went so he got caught because of
these women that came forward in this
documentary
and uh
one of the basically actually what
happened was
um
someone someone wrote an article about
him and it went super viral and one of
his current girlfriends read the article
while she was waiting for him to like
get into town wow she was like holy [ __ ]
that's my boyfriend he's doing the exact
same thing to me so she reported him to
the authorities when he was flying
somewhere and they arrested him at the
airport and uh he got sentenced to like
a year and a half in jail and he got out
in five months and now he's just back in
israel doing the same [ __ ] yeah and he's
still out there just he deleted his
instagram a few days ago but prior to
like videos of him and like ferraris and
all kinds of [ __ ] there's no [ __ ] way
that he's gonna be able to do this scam
again without like getting plastic
surgery or something well dude so he
tried to he tried to try to get a girl
to fund him
for plastic surgery and it didn't it
didn't work out they they went to the
doctor and the doctor was like i'm not
gonna do this because everyone that
wants this surgery is a criminal and his
girlfriend knew at that point whoa and
she was like wanted to scream out like
he is a [ __ ] criminal that's why he
wants this yeah wow
is he in the duck
uh no they tried to but he they tried to
get him and he [ __ ] sent them a voice
note being like oh
this this is [ __ ] i'm not gonna you
know these these women are liars and
this and that but what's crazy is that
he
all of his communication with his
girlfriends is over whatsapp and he'll
just like they communicate in voice
notes and videos so there's like a
million videos of him being like oh
goodnight baby this is the most
embarrassing [ __ ] ever such a european
thing to do yeah it really is
the funniest part is like there's a
moment in the dock where they line up a
couple of videos that he recorded from
the same plane for each of the girls
so it's like one is like him like in the
same outfit being like emily i love you
uh priscilla so good to the and like and
then
this is too much [ __ ] work that's
what i yeah like christ yeah but you
know it's pretty easy to work on a pj we
gotta give them i don't know what on a
pj private jet oh right right right for
sure yeah cut that out agree what a pj
was
hey don't abbreviate dj's
weird
sounds like you don't i don't know i
feel like we got to hear his side of the
story though yeah that's what he said
i'm pretty sure yeah he said he like
posted before he deleted his instagram
he posted and he's like there's two
sides to every story like please keep an
open heart and an open mind before you
hear my side it's like hey tinder
swindler come out tell us come on the
pod that actually would be cool he has a
um like a business program that he says
oh he should come montrell in her
mindset yeah yeah all hawk is business
program yeah i kind of like his current
business program i've heard about yeah
he's honestly kind of killing it yeah
i've only learned a little bit you've
built this company where you have women
take out payday loans for you amazing
work tell us more yeah how does it work
yeah well you basically lie to these
chicks and
sure sometimes you go to jail but that's
just the cause of doing business yeah
but number one number one thing you
gotta do eat [ __ ]
[ __ ]
have you ever spent any time in new york